let's start with our classic system that
i keep using over and over again and
that's because it tends to be very
useful for instruction and it also tends
to be the system that is most covered in
classrooms so hopefully it'll be
productive for you and your schoolwork
so i have this container it has a
movable piston on top or kind of a
movable ceiling that and on top of that
well of course inside of my system i
have a bunch of
molecules or atoms bouncing around
creating some type of
pressure on the system so let's say it
has some pressure p1 this volume right
here let's call that v1 and let's say it
also has some temperature that it starts
off with everything is in equilibrium
remember these are macro states the only
way that can even tell you what the
volume or the pressure or the
temperature is
is if the system is in equilibrium if
everything in it is uniform the
temperature is consistent throughout
fair enough in order to keep it placed
down i have to put some rocks on top
rocks on top and i've done this in
multiple processes so far
and of course i'm doing these little
pebbles because i'm going to remove them
slowly because i want to approximate a
quasi-static process i want to
approximate a system that's always close
enough to equilibrium that i'm cool with
defining our macro states our pressure
our temperature or our volume let me
write v for volume now in this video i'm
going to study what's called an
isothermic process
isothermic
really what it just means is i'm going
to keep the temperature the same iso
just means the same you probably
remember when we studied the periodic
table isotopes those are the same
element just with different mass numbers
so this is the same temperature we're
going to run our process so my question
is how can we do that because as i
remove pebbles
as i remove pebbles
what's going to happen
if i just did it in a cl if i just did
this without any if it was completely
isolated from the world and actually
i'll add a word right here if it was an
adiabatic process
if it was adiabatic
adiabatic fancy word all that means is
completely isolated from the world so no
heat is going into or out of this system
if this was the case what would happen
as i release as i released or i took
away some of these little particles let
me
copy and paste it
let me well let me just redraw it
actually
so i have my
one wall
i have another wall i have another wall
as i release a couple of pebbles you
know one at a time my volume is going to
increase so i'm going to have a slightly
higher volume
my volume is going to go up i have fewer
pebbles here now
and fewer pebbles and since i have the
same number of molecules
they're going to bump into this less so
pressure is going to go down
volume is going to go up and if i was
adiabatic if i if i had no extra heat
being added to the system what do i know
is going to happen to the temperature
well think about it this way some work
was done right our old our old ceiling
was maybe someplace around here we
pushed it up
with some force for some distance so we
did work and so we changed some kinetic
energy or we transferred some kinetic
energy out of the system that's
essentially what the work did that
kinetic energy was turned into work and
temperature is just a macro measure
of average kinetic energy
average kinetic
energy in fact we just well i won't go
into it in the but in the in the in the
in the last video the kind of proofy one
if you didn't watch it because you
didn't want to go through the math which
is completely fair enough because it
normally wouldn't be done in intro
chemistry class i showed that the
internal the internal energy is equal to
the total kinetic energy so total
kinetic energy which was equal to three
halves times the number of moles times r
times temperature so temperature is just
by some scaling factor a measure of
kinetic energy now if some of my when i
do some work
it's essentially a transfer of kinetic
energy right and i can't replace that
energy with some heat because it's
adiabatic there's no heat going into or
out of this system so in that situation
the kinetic energy of the system went
down the average kinetic energy of the
system went down so the temperature
would have also go down
so the temperature would also go down
and actually just as a bonus point what
happened to the internal energy
well the internal energy is the total
kinetic energy of the system and i can
even write down the original formula
change in internal energy
is equal to change
let me do not do that because i said i
shouldn't is equal to heat added to the
system
minus
work done by the system this is work
done by the system that's why we're
subtracting it now it's adiabatic so
there's no heat added to the system so
the change in internal energy is equal
to the is equal to the minus the work
done by the system well in this
situation the system did do work it
pushed this piston up by some distance
with some force so your delta u is
negative it's less than zero so u
went down and that makes sense if
temperature changed then the internal
energy is going to change and for our
simple system where internal energy is
represented by the kinetic energy of
these molecules that's always going to
be the case that if temperature doesn't
change internal energy won't change if
temperature goes up internal energy goes
up if temperature goes down internal
energy goes down and of course they're
not the same thing though there's the
the difference between internal energy
and temperature is the scaling factor
three halves times the number of
molecules times
times our ideal gas constant
so fair enough so if i i do went through
this whole exercise just to show you
that if i was completely isolated and if
i removed a couple of these pebbles that
my temperature is going to go down now i
told you already that i want to do an
isothermic process
i want to do an isothermic process so i
want to do this process while keeping
the temperature the same so how can i do
that
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
place i'm going to place my system on
top of what we'll call a reservoir
a reservoir
so a reservoir you can kind of view as
an infinitely large
amount of something that is the
temperature that we started off with so
this reservoir is t1
so
even though if you know if i took if i
took
you know two things two relative things
of comparable size
let's say a
that says temperature a this is
temperature b and i put them next to
each other they're gonna average out to
a plus b over two whatever their
temperatures are but if b is massive if
you know if a is is just like a i don't
know is a is a is just a speck of of of
particle uh let's say it's an iron dust
while b is the eiffel tower then
essentially b's temperature will not
change a lot a will just become b's
temperature now reservoir is
theoretically infinitely large
it's an infinitely large object so if
something is next to a reservoir and
it's given enough time it'll always
assume the heat of the reservoir or the
temperature of the reservoir so what's
going to happen so this is adiabatic but
now i'm actually putting it next to a
reservoir so this isn't going to happen
the adiabatic situation isn't going to
happen now i'm going to have a situation
where i'm going to stay the same
temperature so what's that going to look
like on the pv diagram
so let me
let me draw the pv diagram
this is my pressure this is my volume so
this is my starting point
right here
and what i'm saying is if i'm doing an
isothermic process so i just keep
removing i just keep removing these
pebbles so i start at this state right
here
and let me copy and paste it since i've
done so much art already here
so i'm going from there
i'm going from there to here
where i'm removing a couple of the
particles
i'm removing a couple of the particles
so let's say i've removed a couple of
them over here and because of that
i've increased the volume so let's say
the volume it's not there anymore let's
say it's a little bit higher let's say
the volume is
just for the sake of our discussion
let's say the volume is expanded a
little bit because i've removed some
particles the little pebbles on the top
keeping it down
so it's like the adiabatic process but
instead of the temperature going down my
temperature stays at t1 my temperature
is at t1 the entire time because i'm
next to this theoretical thing called a
reservoir
right called a reservoir so because of
that i will travel along what we'll call
an isotherm so this is my first state
when i'm done i might end up someplace
over here
and so this is state two so this is
state two this is state one one two what
i'm claiming is that my path
along this is going to be on some type
of a rectangular hyperbola or at least
part of it if i were to add rocks to it
if i were to add rocks and compress it i
claimed that my pv diagram would go like
this if i were to keep removing rocks
from this diagram i claimed that my pv
diagram would keep going like that and
so what's the intuition that if i keep
the temperature constant then i'm
essentially moving along this hyperbola
let's just take out the ideal gas
formula let me
box off all this stuff over here if i
just take the ideal gas formula pv is
equal to n
r d
if t is constant
we know that r is a constant it's the
ideal gas constant we know that we're
not changing the number of moles of
particles then that means that pv is
equal to some constant right this whole
thing is equal to some constant and then
if we wanted to write p as a function of
v we would just write p is equal to k
over v
now this might not look 100 familiar to
but if i wrote an algebraic terms if i
wrote if i told you to graph
y is equal to 1 over x what does that
look like that's a rectangular hyperbola
that looks like this
if this is the y-axis that's the x-axis
at least in this quadrant it looks like
this
it also looks like that in the third
quadrant but we won't worry about that
too much so whenever you hold
temperature constant you're on some
rectangular hyperbola like this like an
isotherm now if the temperature was a
different temperature if it was a lower
temperature you would be on a different
isotherm
so you would be on an isotherm that
looked like this maybe over here
it would also be a rectangular hyperbola
but at a lower state why is that because
if you're at a lower temperature
for any
for any volume
if you're at a lower temperature you
should have a lower pressure and that
works out that's why this is
this is some temperature t2 that is
lower than t1 so i want to do a couple
of things in this video i inadvertently
explained to you what an adiabatic
process is and why the temperature would
naturally go down on its own if you
didn't have this this reservoir here but
the whole reason why i even thought
about doing this video is because i
wanted you to get comfortable with this
idea of one that they a reservoir will
keep you in kind of an isothermic state
it will keep the temperature the same
and then if you keep the temperature the
same that you will travel along this
isotherm
these rectangular hyperbolas and that
each temperature has associated with an
isotherm
so if you take that let's just do one
more step and let's think about the
actual work we did
let's think about the actual work we did
by traveling from this state to this
state or if you just want to think of it
in visual terms from removing our
pebbles slowly and slowly with this
reservoir down here the whole time from
this date to this date where our volume
has increased our pressure has our
volume has increased our pressure has
gone down but our temperature has stayed
the same
the entire time
so
several videos ago we learned that the
work done is the area under this graph
it's the area
under that graph
or if we want to do it in calculus terms
and i'm about about to break into
calculus so if you don't want to see
calculus cover your eyes or ears
it would be the integral and this the
rest of this video will be a little bit
mathy and i guess i should make that
statement on the
on the the title of the video
but if i want to calculate what this
area is i can now do this the the
isotherm assumption makes our math a
little bit easier
because we know that pv is equal to n
r t ideal gas law or we could say p
if you divide both sides by v is equal
to n r t divided by v so there we have
it we have p as a function of e this
this function right here this graph
right here
is this we could write p as a function
of v is equal to n r d over v so if we
want to figure out the area under the
curve we just integrate this function
from our starting our v1 to our ending
point to our v2
so what is that going to be
well we're going to integrate from v1 to
v2 actually this isn't that shouldn't be
equal this is the work
is going to be the integral from v1 to
v2
times our
function p as a function of v
times dv
right we're summing up all the little
all the little rectangles here we did
that a couple of videos ago
so what's p as a function of v so work
done is equal to from v1 to v2
nrt
over
over v
times dv
now this is our simplifying assumption
we said we were sitting on top of a
reservoir that this reservoir keeps our
temperature the same the whole time and
we're going to learn in a second it's
doing that by transferring heat into the
system and we're going to calculate how
much heat is transferred into the system
so if we look at this right here
temperature since we're assuming is that
we're on an ice there is a constant n
and r are definitely constants so we can
write rewrite this integral
as
the integral from v1 to v2
of
1 over vdv and then we could put the nrt
out here i should have done that first
nrt it's just a constant term
now what's the anti-derivative of 1 over
v it's the natural log of v so our work
is equal to
n
rt
times
the natural log this is the
anti-derivative of v
evaluated at
v2 minus it evaluated at v1
so that is equal to
n
rt
times
evaluated v2 so natural log of v2 minus
the natural log of v1
now we know from logarithm properties is
the same thing as
n r t
times
the natural log
of v2
over
v1 so there you have it we actually
calculated the real value if we know our
our starting volume
and our finishing volume we can actually
figure out the work done in this
isothermic process
the work done in this isothermic process
is the area under this and we figured
out what it was
by pushing up that piston it was nrt
these are you know the number of moles
we have ideal gas constant our
temperature that we're sitting on it
would be t1 in this case and the natural
log of our finishing volume divided by
our starting volume
now let me ask a follow-up question how
much heat was put into the system
how much heat was put into the system by
this isotherm
here
how much heat was put into the system
it put in heat to keep the temperature
up otherwise the temperature would have
gone down right heat was going into the
system the entire time how much was it
well
since it's an isotherm since the
temperature did not change what do we
know about the internal energy did the
internal energy change the temperature
not changing told us that the kinetic
energy didn't change if the kinetic
energy didn't change then the internal
energy did not change
and we know
we know
that the change in internal energy is
equal to the heat put into the system
minus the work done by the system
now if this is zero
so we know that this didn't change
because the temperature didn't change so
that means zero is equal to q minus w
or that q
is equal to w
so this is the work done by the system
you'll end up getting something in
joules and this is also equal to the
heat put into the system it's also equal
to q
so when you look at this if we were to
just draw this part of
of the the curve
if i were to let me redraw just to make
things neat i want to give you a little
bit of the convention of what people in
the thermodynamics world tend to do
make a neat drawing here
we started here at state one
and we moved along this rectangular
hyperbola which is an isotherm
to state 2
to state 2.
and now we could have calculated we
calculated the area
under this which is the work done which
was this value right here
let me write it there it's
nrt natural log of v2 over v1 this is v2
this is v1 this whole axis remember was
the v-axis volume axis this axis here
was the pressure axis and the convention
is is that because we did work but we
were
constant temperatures so our internal
energy didn't change
we had to add energy to the system to
make up for the work we did so some heat
must have been added to the system and
what they do is they just put this
little downward arrow and they write a q
right there
so some heat was put into the system
during this this isothermic process
right there and the value of that q is
equivalent to the work we did
we put the exact amount of heat into the
system as the work that was performed
and because of that our internal energy
didn't change or you could say our
temperature didn't change or you could
go the other way because our temperature
didn't change these two things have to
be equal anyway i want to leave you
there hopefully give you a little bit
more of an intuition of how pv diagrams
work a little bit more intuition behind
what isotherms and adiabatic mean and
the most important thing is once we get
a little bit mathy this result can be
useful for coming up with other
interesting things about a lot of these
thermal systems that we're dealing with
see in the next video